good afternoon and welcome to the
National Press Club I'm mark Hamrick of
Associated Press where I'm a broadcast
and online journalist covering business
and financial news
and in this capacity on the 104th
president of the National Press Club we
are the world's leading professional
organization for journalists committed
to our professions future through our
programming events such as this while
fostering a free press worldwide for
more information about the National
Press Club we'd invite you to visit our
website at www.prairiepathcycles.com
lack of journalistic objectivity
we'd also like to welcome our c-span and
public radio audiences our luncheons are
also featured are a member produced
weekly podcasts from the National Press
Club which is available for free
download on iTunes you can also follow
the action on twitter using the hashtag
pound
NBC lunch after our guest speech
concludes we'll have Q&A and we'll ask
as many questions as time permits now
it's time to introduce our head table
guests and please note that a journalist
presence at any head table particularly
during this political season does not
imply or signify an endorsement of the
speaker so would ask each of you here at
the head table to please stand up
briefly as your name is announcement
begin from your right we begin with Paul
schenkman who's a reporter with WTOP
news and we might note a third
generation Press Club member which is a
special thing Heather for screen weaver
is a freelancer and she is with our book
and author committee leadership Ron
bagans of the Kuwait news agency by the
way he hails from the US south he is a
chair of our newsmakers committing and
doing a great job there as well Christin
Grantham is communications director with
SpaceX and a guest of ours
welcome Tim Angela growlin King is a
transportation reporter with Bloomberg
News and our membership secretary on our
board of governors tim hughes is general
counsel with spacex and guests of our
speaker skip over the podium for a
moment Melissa Charbonneau with news
hook media is our fantastic speakers
committee chair really doing a wonderful
job for us there this year thank you so
much Melissa will skip over our speaker
for just a moment Lee Perryman is
director with en PS with Associated
Press he's the speaker's committee
member who organized today's event thank
you very much Lee
George Dewey is senior vice president
marketing and communications with SpaceX
the guests of our speaker welcome Frank
mooring is deputy managing editor for
space Aviation Week and space technology
magazine
Robert Schlesinger is opinion editor US
News and World Report Adam Cano is vice
president client strategy with TMP
government a vice-chair of our broadcast
committee here at the National Press
Club please give them all a warm round
of applause
one might be inclined to call our guest
speaker today a Renaissance man
but to do that would be set him back
several hundred years so that wouldn't
be fair
but with South African and Canadian
heritage he is an engineer whose passion
for solving problems necessitated that
he become an entrepreneur an inventor
we're told that he multitasks that he's
a workaholic
we're told he got in at 3 a.m. this
morning here he probably drives fast
we're told but with a preference for
energy-efficient vehicles and he thinks
a lot about life in space from software
businesses to the internet let's not
forget about electric cars solar energy
and space rockets his friends say that
our speaker today does everything with
absolute conviction even when he
believes in something when he believes
in something he is unstoppable he is
said that if he thinks the stakes are
important enough he'll do it whether the
odds of success are high or low in
February Forbes magazine ranked him as
one of the nation's 20 most powerful
CEOs 40 and under last year time listed
him as one of the 100 people who most
affect the world
Esquire said that he's one of the 75
most influential people of the 21st
century and there been many other awards
and recognitions along the way he bought
his first computer at the age of 10 he
taught himself how to program that and
by the age of 12 he sold his first
commercial software a space game for the
Commodore 64 platform for about five
hundred dollars at age 17 in 1988 he
left his native South Africa for Western
Canada to live and work with his
mother's family in 1992 he won a
scholarship to the University of
Pennsylvania where he received an
undergraduate degree in business from
the Wharton School he got a second
bachelor's degree in physics he headed
to Stanford in a graduate program and
applied physics and material science a
goal was to create ultra capacitors with
enough energy to power electric cars but
after two days he left to start a
company with his brother which provided
online content publishing software for
news organizations and kucing in 1999
Alta Vista acquired that for about 341
million dollars next
guest speaker co-founded an online
financial services an email payment
company you probably have heard of it in
2001 that became PayPal which was
acquired by eBay for 2000 in 2002 for
1.5 billion dollars in stock so I used
the proceeds to help start Space
Exploration Technologies in 2002 where
he is CEO and CTO in 2008 SpaceX won a
NASA contract to replace the cargo
transport function of the space shuttle
to support the International Space
Station with astronaut transport in mind
and a 2009 SpaceX's Falcon 1 rocket
became the first privately funded liquid
fueled vehicle to put a satellite into
Earth orbit he is known as an original
investor chairman of the board and
eventual head of product design at Tesla
Motors where he led design of the
all-electric Tesla Roadster today Tesla
also sells electric powertrain systems
to Daimler and Toyota he is the primary
investor and non-executive chairman of
Solar City our guest speaker has been
compared to Henry Ford Howard Hughes and
even the fictional Tony Stark Iron Man
he has been described as the inspiration
for Robert Downey jr. --zz
interpretation of the character and he
had a cameo in Iron Man 2 appropriately
enough the SpaceX Factory was used in
the film
we hope he got some money from that as
well he's not without critics and
skeptics however including some who
doubt that SpaceX's economies of scale
can sustain the low cost business model
but he insists that he is proving them
wrong
today so the founder of PayPal the
world's largest internet payment system
CEO and product architect at Tesla
Motors manufacturer of the all-electric
Tesla Roadster automobile and Model S
sedan and non-executive chairman of
Solar City a leading provider of solar
power systems in the US is here today
and we're grateful for that to talk
about the future of human spaceflight as
head of SpaceX developer of rockers and
rockets and vehicles for missions to or
'the earth orbit and beyond our guest
view space exploration as a key next
step in preserving and expanding human
life and he's promoted making life
multiplanetary starting with mars it is
an appropriate follow-up to our luncheon
this summer that featured NASA
trader charles bolden and astronaut Mark
Kelly all of this serving as proof that
you do not need to be a rocket scientist
to be a National Press Club luncheon
speaker but it helps please give a warm
National Press Club welcome to one of
the most interesting personalities and
entrepreneurs of our day mr. Elon Musk
I will thank you for having me it's
really an honor to speak here for the
National Press Club so I have an
exciting announcement with respect to
space and I think one which should be
provides some inspiration and some
belief that the innovation is alive and
well in America and going in really
interesting directions but before I I'm
gonna get to that but I'm gonna preface
that with the logic that explains why
such thing as important because it may
not be immediately obvious so so first
of all the going back to why am I in
space and electric cars and and solar
power and Internet stuff it really it
goes back to what when I was in college
and I was trying to think of what what
were the most important things that
would affect the future of humanity what
could have a significant positive effect
in future humanity and and the three
things that I came up with were the
Internet sustainable energy both
production and consumption and and then
space exploration but specifically
making life multiplanetary and I didn't
expect when I was in college to actually
be involved in all three of those areas
but as a result of some success in the
internet arena that gave me the capital
to get involved in very high high
capital endeavors like cars and rockets
which really are very high capital so
the the reason for is mostly going to
talk about space so I want to explain so
why do I think space is really important
and and what about space and and because
I believe in sort of building things up
from from you know from from a rational
sort of framework of logic
and so you saw it with sort of well how
do you decide that anything is important
and I think the lens of history is a
helpful guide here in that things that
are that may seem important in the
moment but actually aren't that
important in the grand scheme over time
if you if you look at look at things of
a broad span of time the things that
that are less important kind of fall
away and if you look at things from the
broadest possible span of time as it
relates to life itself and the the
evolution of life has been primitive
life started around 3.5 to 3.8 billion
years ago and what are the important
steps in the evolution of life and
obviously there was the advent of single
celled life there was differentiation to
plants and animals there was life going
from the oceans to land there was
mammals consciousness and I would argue
also on that scale should fit life
becoming a multiplanetary and in fact I
think it consciousness it is it's the
next step actually because you you
really kind of need consciousness to
design vehicles that can transport life
over hundreds of millions of miles of
irradiated space to an environment that
they did not evolve to exist in it would
be a very convenient of course if there
was another planet just like Earth
nearby but but that's that's unlikely
and and as it turns out not the case so
so I think you you couldn't really
because there's no way for life to sort
of just by dint of natural selection
just sort of games get over to Mars and
survive he says so you need
consciousness you've got you go to
design so I think I think it is the
natural next natural step so I think if
one could make a reasonable argument
that that something is important enough
to fit on the scale of evolution then
it's it's it's important and may be
worth a little bit of our resources and
and one can also think of it
from the standpoint of of life insurance
there's there's a there's some chance
either as a result of something humanity
does or as a result of something natural
like a giant asteroid hitting us or
something and that that civilization and
life as we know it could could be
destroyed this clear evidence for life
being destroyed multiple times in the
fossil record so we don't need to guess
that this is something that can occur it
has occurred and you know the Permian
extinction being a particularly
interesting one because I think that
that that destroyed so between 90 and 95
percent of all species on earth which
doesn't tell the full story because most
the remaining species were fungi so
unless you're a mushroom you're out of
luck so you know this this if we think
it's it's worth buying life insurance on
an individual level well perhaps it's
worth spending more than suspending
something on life insurance for life as
we know it and and and arguably that
that expenditure should be greater than
zero so then we can just get to the
question of what what is an appropriate
expenditure for for life insurance and
you know it I think it probably if it if
it's something like a quarter of a
percent of the GDP that would be that
would be okay I think most people would
say okay that's that's not too bad you
know it's but you know you don't want
you want you want it to be some sort of
number that is much less than we spend
on health care but maybe more than we
spend on lipstick you know something
like that I'm and I like lipstick it's
not like I've got anything against it so
yeah I can't wait for that comment to go
out there
so that so that that's that's kind of
the thing that I think it's important
that we we give a little bit of our a
mind space towards and I think it's also
what one of the most inspiring and
interesting things that we could try to
do it's it's one of the greatest
adventures that humanity could ever
embark upon and you know like the life
has to be more than about solving
problems you know if if all that life is
about is solving problems why bother
getting up in the morning there are
three things that inspire you to you
know that make you proud to be a member
of humanity and you know the Apollo
program certainly an example of that
it's only a handful of people went to
the moon and and yet actually we all
went to the moon we went with them like
vicariously we shared in that adventure
I don't think anyone would say that that
was a bad idea that that that was great
so you know we need we need more of
those things or at least we need some of
those things and you know even if
someone's in a completely different
industry and in a differently different
walk of life it's still something that's
gonna make you feel good about the world
and that that's why that's another
reason why I think we should try to do
to do these great things so now then
let's get to the question of well how do
you do how do you make life
multiplanetary well what is the what are
the fundamental obstacles to that
because it's all well and good if if
we're not everyone agrees that that's
that's worth worth doing but if we can't
do it well doesn't matter so so the
pivotal breakthrough that's necessary
that some company has to come up with to
make life multiplanetary is a fully and
rapidly reusable or word class rocket
this is a very difficult thing to do
because we live on a planet where it
that is just barely possible if gravity
were a little
it would be easy if it was a little
higher it would be impossible so even
for an expendable launch vehicle you
know where you don't attempt any
recovery after a lot of smart people
have done their best to optimize the
weight of the vehicle and the efficiency
of the engines and the guidance system
everything you get maybe 2 to 3 percent
of your liftoff weight tool to orbit but
that's not a lot of room for error so if
your rocket ends up being up just a
little little bit heavier you get
nothing to orbit and this is why only a
few countries have ever reached orbit
now I say ok well let's make it reusable
which means you've got to strengthen the
stages you're going to add a lot of
weight a lot of thermal protection
you've got to do do a lot of things that
that add weight to to that vehicle and
still have a useful payload to orbit
this is nice thing of that meteor 2 to
3% over and maybe if you really could
get it to fall you've got to add all
that all that's necessary to bring the
the rocket stages back to the launch pad
and be able to reflow them and still
have useful payload to orbit so a very
difficult thing that this has been
attempted many times in the past and
generally what's happened is when people
have concluded that success was not one
of the possible outcomes then that the
project's been abandoned well in some
some government projects kept going even
even when success was not one of the
possible outcomes unfortunately but then
eventually they get cancelled so so it's
just a very tough engineering problem
and it wasn't something that I thought I
wasn't sure it could be solved for for a
while but then I think just just so
relatively recently progressed in the
last 12 months or so I've come to
conclusion that better can be solved and
and I think if SpaceX is going to try to
do it now we could fail I'm not saying
we were a certain of success here but
but we're going to try to do it and and
we have a design that
on paper during the calculations doing
the simulations it does work and now we
need to make sure that those simulations
and reality agree because generally when
when they don't reality wins so that
that's a recipe to to be to be
determined and and the simulation that
you may have seen in the lobby coming in
I wish will be posted to our website
right around now is it will show you a
simulation of what we what we plan to do
now that simulation is is mostly
accurate but there are a few areas which
are inaccurate in some cases just due to
timing constraints we weren't able to
work with the simulation people to to
get it completely accurate in some cases
we're keeping a few technical things
under our hat but it gives you a pretty
good idea of what we intend to do which
is to land with basically for the first
stage after stage separation turn the
stage around relight the engines boost
back to the launch pad and land for
possibly on on landing legs and then
with the upper stage after dropping off
the satellite or Dragon spacecraft then
do a deorbit burn re-enter you need a
quite a powerful heat shield steer
aerodynamically back to the launch pad
you don't actually need wings by the way
the converse perception to sterically
just need a some left over drag number
and looked at lift vector and it's
Devaki launch pad then land propulsively
with the upper stage also with landing
gear and so we'll see if this works but
it's going to be certainly an exciting
journey and if it does work it'll be
it'll be pretty huge because if you look
at say that the cost of our Falcon 9
rocket which is quite a big rocket it's
about a million pounds of thrust the and
it is the lowest cost rocket in the
world but in even so it's it's about
fifty to sixty million dollar
and but but the cost of the fuel and
oxygen and so forth is is only about two
hundred thousand dollars so it's
obviously if we can reuse the rocket say
a thousand times then that would make
the capital cost of the rocket for
launch only about fifty thousand dollars
you know there'd be maintenance and
other things that would factor in there
in fixed costs and some overhead
allocation or whatnot but it would allow
for about a hundred fold reduction in in
launch costs and and this this is a
pretty obvious thing you think about it
as applied to any other mode of
transport you can imagine that if planes
were not reusable very few people would
fly you know 747 is about three hundred
million dollars you'd need two of them
for a round-trip and yet I don't think
anyone here has paid half a billion
dollars to fly and the reason is because
those planes can be used tens of
thousands of times and so all you're
really paying for is fuel and pilot
costs and you know it just might sort of
incidentals and the capital cost is
relatively small so that that's why it's
such a giant difference or thought of
another way I mentioned that you know we
could probably afford a quarter of a
percent of our GDP for making life
multiplanetary that that's the cost if
you have a fully reusable rocket but the
cost if you don't have a fully reusable
rocket on the same barometer would be a
hundred percent of the GDP and that
would mean no money for food healthcare
or anything else and obviously that's
impossible
so that's why I think a fully unwrapped
Leary usable system is fundamentally
required for life become multiplanetary
for us to establish life on on mars mars
is the only realistic option for another
planet venus being too hot mercury being
way too hot Jupiter being a gas giant
and the moons of Jupiter a possibility
but it's much further out and it harder
in a lot of different ways and moon is
sort of too small and resource-poor to
have to make life multiplanetary
emphasized not not just to have a little
base a little base is not that
interesting but a self-sustaining human
civilization is that that's on multiple
planets that where life could continue
even in the event of a climate you know
that is the real thing
yeah so so I think this is this is
pretty exciting and I think everyone and
everyone in American and arguably
breasts the world should be pretty fired
up about what what we're doing and
hopefully wish us well and we'll do our
best to succeed in this regard and yeah
it's as if they're definitely gonna be
an adventure and I'll say one final
thing which is that sometimes people say
well what is the business model for Mars
and sometimes they think well can we can
you mine Mars and bring things back and
like that is not a realistic business
model for Mars because that it's always
gonna be far cheaper to mine things on
Earth and Mars but I do think that
there's a business model where if you
can reduce the cost of a flight to Mars
or moving to Mars to around the cost of
middle class home in California which I
just seem to be rising over time maybe
not recently but certainly yeah pretty
expensive so maybe to around half a
million dollars then then I think you'd
have enough people would buy a ticket
and move to Mars to be part of creating
a new planet and be part of kind of a
founding team of a new civilization you
don't have to have to have you know so
you have to be willing to you know we
have a quite an appetite for risk and an
adventure
but I there's seven billion people on
earth now there'll be probably eight
billion by the midpoint of the century
so even if one in a million people
decided to do that that's still eight
thousand people and I don't think
probably more than 1 million people
would say do that so that that's what I
think is sort of the Maz business model
if you will and then ultimately Mars can
probably export intellectual property
like software and inventions and things
like that and if you can sort of beam it
back with photons that's the sort of the
better way to go all right so I'm happy
to answer any questions
well thank you very much obviously given
the diverse nature of your own interest
and pursuits we'll ask you to stay here
as soon as you grab a drink of water
which is required on earth if you what
to the moon that might be more difficult
so we're gonna start with the space
piece and if you'll just stand up here
right by my side and we'll just sort of
wing it
one by one talk about how you see the
practical application of this technology
that you just described sort of in the
near and intermediate term if it's if
it's successful well in the in the near
term the technology will be applied to
launching satellites and to resupplying
the space station taking cargo and crew
up there that's that's the near-term
thing and that's that's what SpaceX is
current business is predicated on we're
doing okay in that regard we've got
about three billion dollars of Revenue
under contract and that's better than
okay yeah yeah I mean it's it's spread
out over the next five years but it's
not all at once fortunately and we do
have to lots of things to get that money
but but but it's but that's not bad
and so we have been profitable for the
last four years not hugely profitable
moderately possible and we expect to be
the same this year so and I think that's
not necessary because obviously if the
amount of money going out exceeds the
amount of money coming in then sooner or
later we'll die so we have to make sure
that that we have a mobile money coming
in than going out but that seems to be
going with me well and you described to
me earlier that right now you're the
leading essentially vendor for launching
satellites into space right now well it
if measured by launch contracts awarded
that is correct and it's so the United
States has been uncompetitive in the
international launch market for a long
time and Russia has actually been leader
in that regard followed by your
and then to a lesser degree India and
China although China's obviously China's
growing rapidly and except in the last
few years where where the United States
has done the best and that's your entire
leader SpaceX so obviously you're a
person very interested and performing in
innovation and that's something it seems
the United States does well in the space
business specifically how can we
maintain that competitive edge and are
we maintaining it in the sector
generally within our nation right now
well as far as launch is concerned I
think I think it's fair to say that the
United States has by far the most
competitive launch capability with
SpaceX as a result of SpaceX and the
only realistic potential competitor is
China it is but the easiest thing
competing with the national governments
which are heavily subsidized and and
they certainly have set their sights on
us and have told us that but but that's
okay I think we won the but we have
actually with respect to China we have a
conscious strategy of filing the
absolute minimum number of patents we
filed very few patents and the Rockets
we were very careful about cybersecurity
and we're very careful about physical
security because there's obviously a
history of absconded with intellectual
property in China and the enforceability
of patents against Chinese government is
zero
so that that's that's difficult contrast
that to Tesla where which has allows a
lot of patents because competitors are
commercial companies and there's
unfortunately so not to worry about
launch will take care of that let me
come back around a little bit to the
maintaining the national standard as you
know there's been an active debate in
Congress we're in Washington about you
know what is the appropriate role for
government of course there was a
different approach to that in times
where cash was more flushed right and it
seems to some degree or a great degree
you're a beneficiary of that in the
sense that we're outsourcing some of
this within our own country now is the
inability the apparent inability of the
federal government to spend on this
going to be an inherent problem for our
country well we do spend a fair bit on
space I mean much more than any other
country from a government standpoint so
I think it's what will continue to be
the biggest spender on space the United
States but but but i but but really I
think the the budgets in in absolute
terms what will decrease just because of
overall compression on the federal
budget and we have a with a huge budget
crisis and largely have our head in the
sand are ignoring the the reality that
we're spending far more than were
bringing in and that chicken will come
home to roost so so I think we can
expect massive compression of all
budgets including space from a
government standpoint just because we
were simply won't have any other choice
well I want to get more to the SpaceX
piece but since you just now talked
about sort of the way that you should do
business as a government there's
obviously a political issue right now
that's out there about how what is the
appropriate role of government in
encouraging job creation you have 1500
employees at SpaceX you're having those
jobs in the United States I guess you
have a launch facility in the Marshall
Islands yeah well actually our primary
launch facility is Cape Canaveral and
then we're building a motor side at
Vandenberg Air Force Base in California
we're not currently using the Marshall
Islands launch site but we did use that
initially but the logistics are just too
difficult getting out there because like
water world out there it's zillion miles
from anywhere so it's convenient in some
ways but but then in community from
logistic standpoint so so far more
societies Cape Canaveral and then
Vandenberg and we're also planning on
establishing a commercial launch launch
site which would because I mean it makes
sense because banovic and the Cape
actually Air Force bases and it makes
sense to sort of concentrate Air Force
and perhaps NASA business at those two
facilities and then concentrate
emotional activity at a commercial one
site just as that as occurs with
aviation
so what's your sense as in the political
debate here in Washington do you have
trouble creating jobs within your
company because of the way the federal
government is operating currently or
what you envision is the way the policy
is managed generally well there are III
should first of all say that you know
SpaceX would not be where it is without
the help of NASA both historically the
great things that NASA has done and and
currently with the business that NASA
gives us so and and in the expert advice
and everything so I I should make sure
they're very strongly credit NASA in
this in this arena in terms of how
helpful they've been we do have a bit of
a challenge with with the Air Force and
but this is something where I'm sort of
surprised that there's not more
journalistic interest because the Air
Force is currently proposing to extend
the socialist monopoly of Boeing and
Lockheed until 2018 and the the
reasoning given for that is preservation
of the industrial base although for some
reason oddly enough we're not included
in the industrial base
and and this is doubly odd because the
main rocket used by Boeing Lockheed is
the Atmos 5 which has a Russian main
engine and a center airframe the
interstage and a ford airframe the
fairing which made in Switzerland
so which industrial base are we talking
about preserving the one in Russia that
doesn't make much sense
so you sense that's a political problem
you know we have 1% of the lobbying
power Boeing and Lockheed that's a
political problem if this decision is
made as a function of loving power we
are screwed I think you just are well
let's get a little bit more to the space
business here because we do have a lot
of questions and I want to make sure be
fair to our audience to get in as many
of those questions as time permits and
obviously these are some far-flung
questions literally as well as
figuratively someone asks a what will
today's announcement how will today's
announcement divert resources from
sending humans to the International
Space Station and I would probably add
if at all no I wouldn't considers to be
in any way a diversion this is a
parallel effort and so it's not really
impacting our sending of cargo to the
space station
nor is it affecting how human space
flight development activities that we're
doing in partnership with NASA which
which is going really well so think of
this as sort of a parallel thing it
doesn't really affect the ascent phase
of the vehicle but we're really trying
to have the the descent phase not be
hits atmosphere and explodes you know
that's actually what happens to all
rockets otherwise but that's a good goal
to keep given the grounding of Russia's
rocket fleet are you in discussions with
NASA to accelerate launch dates for the
International Space Station missions and
what happens happens with your scheduled
November launch with the possibility
that the ISS may need to be evacuated
yeah
with the Soyuz family that could
recently malai CLE result in a delay in
our launch to the space station because
of that sort of pushes out the other
missions and NASA rightly wants to have
the appropriate level of astronaut the
the right astronauts a number of
astronauts and with the right training
everything onboard the space station
when we arrive so the it looks like
things will be more like January for the
launch the space station and that that
that is contingent upon the Russians the
Russians meeting the schedule that
they're currently stated so how do you
evaluate the fact that we're using
Russia as an important partner in our
space program right now how do you feel
about that what are the risks and what
are the benefits I think I think just
despite the recent failure of the Soyuz
it is actually a good vehicle there's a
good track record I think there may be
some concerns going going to future
long-term with Russia and that a lot of
their expert rocket engineers that have
retired because it's much more
compelling financially to go into the
oil and gas industry in Russia than it
is to go into the rocket industry so
yeah so you sort of that expertise is
tailing off and I I think that may lead
to decreased reliability for for Russian
rockets in the future hopefully it
doesn't but does that give the advantage
to China them well I think I think long
term like I said I think I think China
is is the is is the serious competitor
along to there you know if you look at
Russia and rocketry since the fall of
the Soviet Union there's really been no
significant developments the technology
is no it has barely progressed no no new
rockets have launched since before the
Soviet Union so so so so what that means
is as soon as that technology levels
exceed it then they're rendered
redundant and they have no
to compete and I think that's that's
likely what will occur with the Russian
launch industry so how much longer they
have unless they start doing some
serious work as being a viable space
program they're back to ten years and
how soon does that mean then at that
point China moves in I mean essentially
in that space that they're occupying I'm
quite confident we can take on China yes
well let's get it to another question
I'm confident but I'd rather bet on us
than China well you're on the record and
I think you have a lot of people
cheering for you so obviously we'll see
what happens we'll invite you back could
be famous last words given the failed
progress launch and the risks of
trusting the very survival of the
international space station entirely to
saw use for years to come
there's a something of a state of
emergency until us crews begin can you
fast track development and human rating
to result in crude launches beginning in
about two years and if not can you speed
up the process by any amount could you
want launching an emergency yeah well I
think it's important to clarify what
what can the system do that we've done
you know with the Falcon Iron Dragon
system that we're launching today what
what what can I do if the degree of
safety required was equivalent to that
of the shuttle we could actually launch
astronauts on the next flight on the one
going up in which will likely go up in
January the that the system is fully
capable of carrying biological cargo you
know which is you know people so however
what it doesn't have is a launch escape
system and this is shuttle also does not
have a launch escape system right and
both NASA and we agree that a launch
escape system is is a wise move so we
are it'll take us about two years maybe
the outside three to develop and qualify
a little escape system and in the way
the way we're doing or to escape system
is I think a significant innovation
beyond what's done in the past with the
escape
both into the sidewall of the spacecraft
so you can actually use those same
thrusters for propulsive landing which
is cool and we're actually talking with
NASA about potentially doing missions to
Mars and other places using dragon as
kind of a general test at a general
science delivery platform to various
places in the in the solar system so so
that that's an important distinction we
could all exit motions we could launch
satellites next flight if-if-if
requirements same as shuttle but for if
we want to add launch escape system two
or three years question or ask NASA has
a legacy of openness and transparency
unlike private companies would while
you're flying private payloads a private
model will continue to work for you
however once the American taxpayer
starts footing the bill and I guess the
supposition is here more aggressively
what assurances can you give that SpaceX
will be as open and transparent as NASA
and and other aerospace systems or need
you be well you know we're relatively
speaking a pretty open transparent
company you know there are some
restrictions here which are ITAR
restrictions and they're not
restrictions that you know that we have
any choice of because advanced rocket
technology is considered practice
protected technology so you can do harm
with those all right right you know we
can't give we can't sort of just
published it to the general public
detailed a detailed analysis of failure
investigations that that contain secrets
on how to make rockets that's actually a
violation of the law but we all that
information is available to NASA and to
the FAA so our you know for missions
that we do for NASA nASA has quite a
detailed oversight role and then the FAA
as well has as an oversight role so you
know if you're comfortable flying
commercial aircraft I think you then you
should be pretty comfortable with what
we're doing
in commercial rocketry and yet with NASA
there's obviously any number of tragic
events that occurred where human life
was lost and in the sense that obviously
they're using private companies as
partners but essentially was under the
NASA and government brand essentially
flying the American flag can a company
like yours sustain a loss like that as a
private enterprise would people be
willing to give you as much dare I say
space in the event of a tragedy that
they would be their own government yeah
I think I think I think that'll be okay
I mean if you look at all other modes of
transport aircraft boats cars familiar
with cars the there are there's loss of
life in every mode of transport and if
one set a standard that they you know
you couldn't have loss of life then
there would be no transport you wouldn't
even be allowed to walk so